what we've learned lately is that there
are 17 triggers for flow these are
preconditions that bring on more flow
and when you strip them all down flow
follows focus right it is a state that
can only show up in the now and the
present tense so what all these triggers
are our ways of driving our attention
into the now to put it more formally
that the ways that evolution shaped our
brain pay attention to the moment the
easiest way to act flow and the people
who are most successful at it have built
their lives around these triggers so let
me give you a couple examples there are
three environmental triggers or external
triggers that precipitate flow the first
to them is most obvious its high
consequences when there's a lot of risk
in the environment we pay more attention
to what's going on this is obvious in
action adventure sports which are very
very high in flow produce a lot of flow
obviously a lot of high consequences in
action adventure sports I'm going to
talk to people who are not athletes who
are not interested in this the
interesting thing is you don't need
physical risk you do need risk because
it focuses attention but you can replace
the physical risk with emotional risk
intellectual risk creative risk social
risk social risk works extremely well
because the brain cannot tell the
difference between social fear and
social pain and physical fear and
physical pain the processed in the exact
same structures and it sounds weird
until you realize that go back 300 years
ago and exile meaning social banishment
you screwed up socially tribe kicked you
out it was a capital crime it was
capital punishment you couldn't exist
really outside of the tribe unless maybe
you were Daniel Boone right
we process social fear the same place we
process physical fear which is why for
example fear of public speaking is the
number one fear in the world and it's
not say getting mauled by a grizzly bear
right so taking social risks as a way of
hacking the flow state is perfect so for
a big wave surfer they may have to drop
into a 50-foot wave to pull this trigger
but the shy guy only asked across the
room and speak to the attractive woman
to pull this trigger the shy woman means
to have to
raise their hand and speak up at the
business meeting to pull this trigger
second of these environmental triggers
is what's known as deep embodiment deep
embodiment is a fancy way of saying
we're paying attention to multi-sensory
streams at once right so not only our
five senses but we have proprioceptive
and vestibular awareness so balance and
body position in space all this
information is streaming in all the time
but most of us live our lives as heads
on sticks right we're unaware of this
yet 50% of our nerve endings are in our
hands and feeding face so you wake up
these other senses right when you
capture multiple senses it want it
drives attention into the now so for
example again going back to action in
adventure sports which I focus on a rise
a Superman
deep embodiment shows up all the time
because these athletes are experiencing
zero G's multiple G's and poly axial
rotations so zero G's weightlessness
multiple G's weighted Nisour at the
force of gravity and poly axial rotation
is a fancy way of saying rotation around
your middle we're spinning
we are gravity bound creatures these are
unusual sensations whenever we encounter
them it grabs hold our attention and
drives it into them now of course you
don't have to be an action-adventure
sport athlete to pull this trigger in
fact back in the 90s when researchers
went looking for the highest flow
environments they could find one of them
that they discovered outside of action
budget sports was Montessori education
and one of the reasons is Montessori
education is often called embodied
education which means they emphasize
learning through doing not just learning
through reading so don't just read about
the windmill go out and build one by
building something with your hands or
engaging your tactile senses your brain
your eyes multiple sensory stream drives
attention into the now and in Montessori
education the result is a tremendous
amount of flow since flow amplifies
performance motivation learning
creativity all these other things it's
one of the reasons they give for
explaining when Montessori kids perform
regular kids on just about every test
can imagine social skills intellectual
skills
you